[Music]
I'm so afraid to tell people I mean I
just
this isn't I'm gay I didn't really
realize the impact of it at the time and
people would tell me that there were
parties all over the country it was like
Superbowl it was it was it people left
work early that felt great that felt so
great and it felt so loud there have
been many many people before me stepping
forward and saying that they're gay
certainly I'm the first lead character
and it surprised people because we
didn't start the series with me being
gay we started with me being a
heterosexual woman and then she finds
out she's gay which is a kind of a risk
when people fall in love with a
character and so they like the character
and then all of a sudden you say oh by
the way I'm this which supposedly
everyone in society does not like that's
that's a big risk I'm sensing a little
tension that's right tense tension I
have tension yes you can read vibes yeah
good and that's the thing you keep
hearing the question you know is America
ready was America ready it's you know I
don't think anybody's ever ready for
whenever anybody's the first to do
something I'm not saying I was the first
to do this but for television I was but
nobody's ever ready you can't just wait
for America to be ready for things and
that's how we we have that change you
know people it's like if something works
let's make a million more shows exactly
like that and nobody's willing to risk
and try anything new and we did
something that everyone was scared and
just waiting to say uh we told you that
would that would not work it would fall
apart it would ruin your career and the
fact that we have done this I hope that
more people will take a chance and show
a little more diversity on
exist there are gay people in society
you know there are people of color in
society just why don't we show what
really happens in life instead of it's
like if we had Leave It to Beaver on
still that just does not apply anymore
it didn't apply then you know nobody was
named Ward
[Music]
you